guten abend wir sind live mit zdf heute
live auch wenn es alle nicht wahrhaben
wollen auch dieser sommer wird
vorbeigehen und dann wird die korona
situation vielleicht wieder auch
deutlich angespannter sein als es jetzt
der fall ist gesundheitsminister
lauterbach wegen steuern das hat er
heute im bundestag gesagt
wir dürfen nicht erneut
unvorbereitet wie im letzten herbst in
die krise gehen wir müssen gut
vorbereitet sein wir können es uns nicht
leisten ein weiterer unfall vor
unvorbereiteter herbst wäre nicht
vertretbar aber
werden sich die einen weiter mit corinna
beschäftigen und andere sagen ich kann
jetzt einfach gerade mal gar nichts mehr
davon hören schleicht sich eine ganz
andere pandemie ein und die hat nichts
mit corona zu tun und der hat auch
nichts mit affen brocken zu tun es gibt
experten die sagen das ist die viel
größere bedrohung manche sprechen sogar
von einer globalen krise die rede ist
von multiresistenten keimen wo genau das
problem liegt was diese keime anrichten
können und was dagegen unternommen
werden sollte darüber wollen wir heute
reden deshalb schickt uns eure fragen
eure statements eure erfahrungen gerne
per mail oder einfach in die
kommentarspalten posten bei uns zu gast
ist jetzt gleich sagt saskia nahrgang
sie arbeitet für die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu als
koordinatorin für die überwachung von
antibiotikaresistenzen ja und auch dem
intensivpflege ricardo lange brennt
dieses thema ganz schön unter den nägeln
er ist auch heute bei uns guten abend
herr lange
ja hallo guten abend sie haben es gerade
gehört der gesundheitsminister sagt er
will sich wappnen man muss sich wappnen
und es hieß immer aus corona lernen für
künftige pandemien haben sie den
eindruck dass das gerade passiert also
will sich wappnen gegen korona was
natürlich auch ein wichtiges thema ist
aber während wir uns den kopf um
zukünftige pandemien um kroner machen
läuft seit jahren im hintergrund eines
der größten infektionsgeschehen quasi
endgegner überhaupt in unserem
gesundheitswesen an dem jährlich zig
tausend menschen ich glaube sind 20.000
sterben oder andere körperlich schwere
schäden davon tragen und da wird einfach
überhaupt nichts unternommen da wird
nicht viel darüber berichtet und das
finde ich einfach unmöglich und als
gesundheitsminister sollte oder
bundesgesundheitsminister sollte er
dieses thema zumindest mal thematisieren
und auch auf dem schirm haben und nicht
nur über affen pocken sprechen oder über
corona sind natürlich themen die man im
auge halten muss aber wie gesagt die
multiresistenten keime machen uns im
krankenhaus sprichwörtlich die hölle
heiß wir schauen darauf und vorher
erklärt meine kollegin franziska von
tiesenhausen wie multi resistente
resistente keim es ist aber auch ein
schwieriges wort überhaupt entstehen
multiresistente keime sind bakterien die
gegen mehrere antibiotika unempfindlich
geworden sind aber wie kommt es dazu
bakterien vermehren sich durch teilung
dabei kann sich jedes mal der genetische
code ändern das bezeichnet man als
mutation so können die keime sich neuen
lebensbedingungen anpassen neue
eigenschaften können entstehen bei
bakterien etwa die fähigkeit sich gegen
bestimmte antibiotika zu wehren je mehr
mutationen desto mehr resistenzen können
sich ausbilden hinzukommt
multiresistente keime können die
resistenz nicht nur an ihre nachkommen
vererben sondern auch an andere erreger
in der umgebung übertragen bakterien
sind nämlich in der lage ihre gene
untereinander auszutauschen
im jahr 2019 vor der korona pandemie
sind einer aktuellen studie zufolge mehr
als 1,2 millionen menschen weltweit an
einer infektion mit einem antibiotika
resistenten erreger gestorben die
weltgesundheitsorganisation zählt
resistente keime zu den zehn größten
gefahren für die globale gesundheit
ich sage es gerne noch mal eure fragen
eure kommentare eure statements könnt
ihr uns gerne schicken am besten per
mail oder in die kommentarspalten
schreiben die adresse seht ihr jetzt
auch eingeblendet herr lange wir haben
es gerade gehört die zehn größten
gefahren für die globale gesundheit die
merkt man denn überhaupt dass man sich
so ein multi resistenten keim
eingefangen hat und genau hier ist das
große problem wenn das gesundheits also
quasi das immunsystem intakt dass wenn
wir gesund sind merken wir es eben nicht
aber wenn wir dann zum beispiel ins
krankenhaus kommen so wie es zum
beispiel guten freund von mir passiert
ist der hat sich das bein gebrochen und
dann wird operiert man schneidet in die
intakte haut und dann gelangt diese
multiresistenten keime unter umständen
in die op wunde und normalerweise liste
mit drei tagen dann im krankenhaus
kannst nach hause gehen bei ihm war es
letztendlich zwei monate mit unzähligen
operationen und damit man dem fuß noch
retten konnte und die op wunde
verschließen konnte wurde eben nach wie
gesagt zwei monaten ein muskel strang
herausoperiert aus dem oberschenkel und
in dem fuß verpflanzt nur so konnte man
die wunde wieder schließen und genau
hier wie gesagt ist das problem man
merkt das nicht und erst wenn man krank
wird wenn man operiert wird im
krankenhaus liegt dann werden diese
keime unter umständen zu einer tödlichen
gefahr und damit wir das mal verstehen
warum gelingt es nicht in den
krankenhäusern die verbreitung dieser
erreger einzudämmen da kommen wir wieder
auf den ganz einfachen punkt
personalmangel sie müssen nicht
vorstellen das größte vehikel für solche
krankenhauskeime sind immer auch bei uns
im krankenhaus die hände und da gibt es
natürlich hygieneschulungen und sie
müssen sich vorstellen da kommt so eine
hygienefachkraft auf die stationen wie
ihr desinfizieren ist mit einer
bestimmten lösungen die hände und dann
halten wir den so eine box mit
schwarzlicht und selbst unter diesen
laborbedingungen kommt es immer wieder
vor dass
stellen nicht ausreichend benetzt sind
und im zweifel kann aus keinem
übertragen würden und wenn sie jetzt
aber personalmangel haben hetzen von
einem patienten zum anderen haben wenig
zeit müssen dann auch noch die
einwirkzeit von 30 sekunden halten dann
ist natürlich der übertragungsweg noch
viel viel mehr gewährleistet und das
reinigungspersonal von denen niemand
spricht auch die sind hohen
arbeitsbelastung ausgesetzt und wenn
dies natürlich nicht schaffen oder
fehler passieren einfach weil der
zeitdruck so hoch ist ein
patientenzimmer ausreichend zu reinigen
dann ist der übertragungsweg in auch da
gegeben das ist ein ganz großes problem
hinzu kommt dass patienten die ins
krankenhaus kommen getestet werden auf
multiresistente keime bis das
laborergebnis vorliegt vergehen so
zwischen je nach klinik und labor zwei
bis vier tage und in dieser zeit sind
wir als pflegekräfte ärztliches personal
und auch alle art von therapeuten
physiotherapeuten ergotherapeuten
ungeschützt am patient und erst nach
vier tagen wenn das ergebnis kommen
scheiße der patient ist positiv erst
dann wird der patient isoliert wir als
pflegepersonal als medizinisches
personal werden nicht getestet und haben
in den vier tagen das bakterium diese
superkeime unter umständen und mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit an andere patienten
weitergegeben und warum denken sie ist
das thema gefühlt nicht so richtig auf
dem radar weil es niemanden interessiert
ist halt nicht medienwirksam ich habe
schon meine kritik an der lauterbach ist
ja dass einmal von einem medienwirksam
thema zum anderen springt aber dieses
problem besteht schon seit jahren und es
hat einfach keine lobby auch die
pharmaindustrie forscht nicht
ausreichend nach neuen antibiotika weil
es sich einfach finanziell nicht lohnt
sie müssen sich vorstellen jetzt heute
ein neues antibiotikum entwickelt wird
dann gilt es ja als sogenanntes reserve
antibiotikum was entsprechend dann auch
selten eingesetzt wird somit werden
nicht viele maschinen verkauft und da
erwarte ich einfach hier von der
bundesregierung dass sie wie beim krone
impfstoff eine menge geld in die hand
nimmt um ebensolche antibiotika
forschung voranzutreiben denn eins ist
ganz klar wenn uns in ein paar jahren
die letzten reserveantibiotika ausgehen
dann heißt es game over dann werden wir
zurück in die steinzeit katapultiert zu
zeiten wo wir eben noch an ganz normalen
bakteriellen infektionen gestorben sind
weil wir kein antibiotikum mehr hatten
und wenn unser antibiotikum nicht mehr
wirkt dann ist es genau die zeit wie sie
damals war verlange jetzt müssen sie
noch mal ganz kurz erklären was reserve
antibiotika sind also man hat er gewisse
bakterien die lernen mit diesen
antibiotikum umzugehen also es gibt zum
beispiel drei mgm der ist gegen die drei
großen klassen der antibiotika-resistenz
und da hat man noch 12 an die musiker
die da noch wirken und das sind dann die
reserve antibiotika aber es gibt
mittlerweile auch schon keime da hilft
kaum noch ein antibiotikum da muss man
mehrere antibiotika
kombinieren über längeren zeitraum und
wenn uns diese antibiotika ausgehen dann
haben wir keine waffe mehr gegen diese
superkeime dann sind wir diesen
schutzlos ausgeliefert dh die reserve
antibiotika werden zurückgehalten damit
eben nicht sich da auch neue resistenzen
wieder bilden ich würde jetzt gerne die
expertin von der whu in unsere runde
dazu holen guten abend saskia nahrgang
guten abend gut' nahm der lange hat das
ja eben schon
angedeutet oder bzw angedeutet ist gut
er hat schon mit drastischen worten
beschrieben was würde denn passieren
wenn antibiotika nicht mehr zur
verfügung stünden weil sie einfach nicht
mehr wirken
ja so wie lange das schon gesagt hat mit
drastischen worten wir würden wieder in
eine zeit zurückversetzt werden wo es
gar keine antibiotika gab und sie haben
am anfang gesagt das ist ein problem das
sich einschleicht aber das hat sich
schon eingeschlichen seit antibiotika
existieren seit das erste antibiotikum
erfunden wurde war das problem bekannt
dass wenn antibiotika eingesetzt werden
weil es eben auch lebewesen sind kleine
lebewesen mikroorganismen die entwickeln
sich die mode ihren die gewöhnen sich an
diese waffen die wir gegen sie einsetzen
und werden dann widerstandsfähiger und
durch unser verhalten in den letzten 100
jahren also fast so lange gibt es ja
diese antibiotika bereits wo wir die
sehr
missbraucht haben zu viel verbraucht
haben verschrieben haben bei einfachen
erkältungskrankheiten die gar nicht
durch bakterien verursacht werden also
eben nicht nur der krankenhausbereich
sondern auch der ambulante bereich
spielt eine rolle in vielen ländern
europas oder weltweit sollte ich besser
sagen werden antibiotika auch noch über
die
apotheke
frei verkauft oder auch auf dem
schwarzmarkt verkauft also ohne
irgendeine barriere und dieser
missbrauch und fälschliche verbrauch von
antibiotika triggert und treibt das
problem an das ist bekannt seit langem
aber ist wurde halt leider viel zu wenig
dagegen getan und weltweit sieht die
situation schlecht aus und damit hätten
sie die frage von lucas auf youtube auch
schon beantwortet der gefragt hat wie
diese keime entstehen würden sie sagen
multiresistente keime haben eine ähnlich
bedrohliche bedeutung für die
gesellschaft wiko wett
absolut also wenn wir jetzt einfach mal
auf die zahlen gucken wie viele
todesfälle seit anbeginn der pandemie
durch cupid verursacht wurden kann da
antibiotika resistenz durchaus mithalten
also die zahlen pro jahr sind in 2009/10
da ist gerade eine neue studie
erschienen der globalen krankheitslast
und da wurden allein im jahr 2009 10
über vier millionen
todesfälle verursacht durch antibiotika
resistenz und
seit anbeginn der pandemie waren es
ungefähr
6,2 millionen todesfälle an kurven 19
das ist durchaus vergleichbar und die
zahlen für
antibiotikaresistenz sind mehr als die
todesfälle an malaria und hiv
mittlerweile
ich hätte noch mal eine frage an herrn
lange
die gibt es von matthias auf facebook
welche patienten sind denn diesbezüglich
besonders gefährdet also besonders
gefährdet sind natürlich immer patient
mit einem schlechten immunsystem also
kranke patienten ältere patienten
aber auch wie gesagt im falle meines
freundes kumpels der ist wirklich nicht
vor erkrankte er sportlich der es fit
der ist aktiv und achtet auf seiner
gesundheit aber wie gesagt wenn man in
ein operationsgebiet schneidet also in
die haut schneidet da können ganz
normale bakterien die jeder auf unserer
haut hat die unter umständen auch schon
multiresistent sind in die wunde
gelangen und dann haben wir echt ein
problem oder wenn darmbakterien die
jeder von uns hat in der wohnung
bekommen oder so das geht ganz schnell
und natürlich ist man immer mehr
gefährdet schwäche das immunsystem ist
aber auch wir gesunden sind davor nicht
gefeit das muss man ganz klar es gibt es
noch eine andere frage von till werden
multiresistente keime durch die
unzähligen desinfektions spender in
jedem laden noch um ein vielfaches
gefördert
also die resistenzen beziehen sich
natürlich immer auf antibiotika und die
dame von welt schon gesagt wie benutzen
antibiotika viel zu oft und viel zu
sorglos aber auch die patienten sind
daran nicht ganz unschuldig denn oftmals
ist es so man kriegt antibiotika
verschrieben nach drei tagen fühlt man
sich besser und denkt sich auch neuer
dann brauche ich nicht zu ende nehmen
und somit sind aber nicht alle bakterien
abgetötet diese überleben dann und
merken sich dieses antibiotikum und beim
nächsten mal hilft dann eben kein
antibiotikum hat das ist das problem
vielleicht noch mal zum verständnis wo
man sich multiresistente keime einfangen
kann da hat sich meine kollegin maria
leidinger für uns schlau gemacht
multiresistente keime entstehen und
verbreiten sich vor allem wenn
antibiotika zu früh zu oft oder falsch
eingesetzt werden einzelne bakterien
überleben dabei passen sich an und
werden resistent
auch der einsatz von so genannten
breitband antibiotika also solche die
mehr als einen erreger bekämpfen fördert
die widerstandskraft der keime
besonders schnell entstehen und
verbreiten sich multiresistente keime im
krankenhaus
hier treffen viele verschiedene
krankheitserreger aufeinander
gleichzeitig werden viele antibiotika
eingesetzt für kaymer das perfekte
trainingslager
ein weiteres problem die
massentierhaltung bei krankheitsfällen
wird meist ja ganze bestand mit einem
antibiotikum behandelt auch wenn nur ein
tier krank ist so entstehen
multiresistente erreger die der mensch
über die nahrung aufnimmt
verbreitet werden resistente keime aber
auch durch unser abwasser
denn ein teil der medikamente scheidet
der körper bei einer antibiotika
behandlung wieder aus das abwasser ist
damit der perfekte ort für die bakterien
um sich abzuhärten und resistent zu
werden resistente keime können dadurch
auch ins frischwasser gelangen zum
beispiel in badeseen
frau jahrgang gehen wir es vielleicht
nochmal durch auf youtube schreibt ein
user können wir dabei bitte auch die
fleischindustrie und massentierhaltung
erwähnen die tragen massiv zum entstehen
von multiresistenten keimen zu was wir
ja gerade gesehen haben was wäre die
lösung dass man fleisch aus
massentierhaltung einfach konsequent
nicht mehr zu sich nimmt
ich denke das kann man so nicht
vereinfachen aber
die die massen half der massenhafte
einsatz von antibiotika in der tierzucht
oder zum mast ist ein problem das auch
schon lange bekanntes deswegen ist es
auch in der eu
verboten allerdings wird auch nach
deutschland und in die eu wird werden
auch produkte importiert von ländern wo
das eben nicht verboten ist und
die massentierhaltung ist nicht ideal
weil eben durch die nähe der tiere
zueinander krankheiten kaymer schneller
verbreitet werden können und auch
resistente keime verbreitet werden
können aber natürlich spielt er auf
faktoren eine rolle wie zum beispiel wie
wir die die nahrungsmittel verarbeiten
sind die ordentlich gekocht worden sind
keime abgetötet worden oder sind die
rohprodukte und so weiter da gibt es
viele viele komplexe faktoren also ich
würde jetzt nicht generell sagen da gibt
es einen faktor wenn wir den beheben ist
das ganze problem weg aber wir müssen
uns darüber gedanken machen und wir
müssen uns für einen aus sinnvollen
antibiotika einsatz im
tierzucht bereich einsetzen und dazu
gehören übrigens auch so sachen wie
aquakulturen also fischzucht wobei eben
auch über das wasser das dann in der
fischzucht mit antibiotika belastet ist
antibiotika in die umwelt gelangen und
wir wissen noch viel zu wenig über die
effekte auf antibiotikaresistenz
entwicklung durch die umwelt durch
abwasser et cetera da gibt es noch viel
zu erforschen
es wurde ja auch eben ein gespann
gesprochen der einsatz von antibiotika
bei menschen ist das immer noch so dass
antibiotika zu oft und zu früh
verschrieben werden verlage
absolut also in deutschland hat sich zum
glück
dann ganz positiver trend abgezeichnet
dass im vergleich zum vorjahr die
antibiotika verbrauch das war glaube ich
eine studie der tk sich 30 prozent
verringert hat das ist ein positiver
trend und das kann auch zusammenhängen
mit hygienemaßnahmen die jetzt während
der kurve zeit eingeführt wurden das
einfach weniger leute im freien waren
also dass die die übertragung von
atemwegserkrankungen dadurch in der
gesellschaft verringert wurde also
atemwegserkrankungen die nicht korrekt
assoziiert sind also da hat es schon ein
paar positive entwicklungen auch
durchaus gegeben aber das hat sehr viel
überzeugungsarbeit gebraucht und in
vielen ländern europas und weltweit wie
gesagt ist der verbrauch von antibiotika
noch völlig unreguliert da gibt es keine
maßnahmen weder im krankenhaus noch im
ambulanten bereich um systematisch
dagegen vorzugehen dass antibiotika für
indikation verschrieben werden wo die
einfach nichts bringen wie zum beispiel
virusinfektionen das hat man übrigens
auch bei chur wird gesehen dass einfach
auf jede infektion wurden auch
antibiotika mit draufgehauen weil man
sich unsicher waren die leute angst
hatten und das hat definitiv nicht den
richtlinien entsprochen und ja das ist
das wahre problem
das heißt man kennt das ja selber vom
hausarzt monaten virusinfekt und dann
bekommt man noch ein antibiotikum damit
sich eben keine bakterielle infektionen
noch auf das geschwächte immunsystem
drauf setzt das wäre dann das plädoyer
dafür da lieber erstmal abzuwarten oder
muss man da individuell herren das ist
dann muss man definitiv individuell
schauen aber ich würde sagen also die
patienten mit denen herr lange sich
auseinandersetzt das sind ja schwer
kranke patienten die sind schon im
krankenhaus die sind vielleicht eben nun
komprimiert die kriegen auch vielleicht
medikamente die sie ihr schon schwächen
da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein mit
solchen empfehlungen die brauchen
möglicherweise wirklich ein antibiotikum
und die sollen das natürlich auch
bekommen wenn sie es brauchen aber dann
das richtige antibiotikum für die
richtige zeit dauer et cetera aber eben
leute die einfach eine
erkältungskrankheit haben die mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit durch ein virus
verursacht ist die könnten auch ohne ein
antibiotikum auskommen und das nennt man
zum beispiel eine watch und waits
strategie also warten ob das wirklich
notwendig wird und und da sollte man
vielleicht etwas mutiger werden auch
wirklich zu warten
verlange also wenn ich dann ein
antibiotikum verschrieben bekomme
trotzdem packung zu ende nehmen auch
wenn es mir schon tage früher wieder
eigentlich ganz gut geht unbedingt weil
nur weil es uns besser geht heißt es ja
nicht dass die keime die bakterien
abgetötet sind sie sind schwächer und
der körper holt sich aber wir müssen
wirklich sicherstellen dass hat auch
wirklich jedes einzige kriterium
vernichtet wird anders kann man es nicht
sagen weil jedes bakterium was überlebt
merkt sich den feind nämlich das
antibiotikum und wie vorhin schon
eindrücklich erklärt gibt diese
informationen dann über das erbgut und
so weiter an seine nachfahren der
vermehrt sicher weiter
susanne schreibt auf youtube
reinigungskräfte in krankenhäusern
müssen einfach mal die zeit eingeräumt
bekommen die sie benötigen um wirklich
auch richtig sauber machen zu können und
dazu gehört auch das desinfizieren
sie bekommen dass matt ist das auch ein
großes problem also die reinigungskräfte
haben in dieser ganzen pandemie meiner
meinung nach zu wenig aufmerksamkeit
bekommen denn die buckeln sich wirklich
den a strom anders kann man es einfach
gar nicht mehr sagen und die machen ja
nicht nur die ganze station darüber
sondern müssen dann extra noch diese
isolation zimmer wenn es zum beispiel
patient verstorben oder verlegt ist oder
verlegt worden ist reinigen und da reden
wir nicht nur von mal so ein bisschen ab
vision sondern da wird alles was auch so
zu desinfizieren geht desinfiziert
weggeschmissen und wenn da ein fehler
passiert und da passiert eben ganz klar
weil die so eine hohe arbeitsbelastung
haben eben schneller mal und genau das
ist wir brauchen mehr von diesen
menschen die eben diese arbeit machen
und diese menschen brauchen bessere
arbeitsbedingungen und vor allem sie
brauchen 1 7 zeit ihre arbeit gründlich
und ordentlich zu machen aber das ist
gar nicht möglich weil die wissen gar
nicht wo sie zuerst anfangen sollen die
sind schon bei der reinigung des zimmers
ruf der operationssaal schneiden wir
brauchen hier eine reinigungskraft der
musterhäuser mal gemacht wenn die herzen
von a nach b genau wie die pflegekräfte
und dann passieren solche gravierenden
hygienefehler das heißt fassen dass man
zusammen die situation ist ja bei ihnen
der pflege ähnlich sie müssen mehr sein
mehr werden sie brauchen mehr zeit und
sie sagen bessere arbeitsbedingungen was
meinen sie genau damit wir brauchen mehr
personal damit man eben a seine
aufmerksamkeit nicht auf so viele
patienten aufteilen muss und wir
brauchen mehr personal dass man ohne
stress ganz konzentriert seine arbeit
machen kann ich hab's davon schöner
klepel dahinter dass infektionen und
herr lauterbach der sich immer als mann
der zahlen als mann der wissenschaft
gibt kennt diese zahlen und es gibt
untersuchungen die wissenschaftlich
beweisen dass je mehr oder etwas mal
andersrum die weniger pflegepersonal vor
ort ist je mehr nosokomiale infektionen
also infektion mit krankenhauskeimen
gibt es je mehr blutvergiftungen also wo
solche keime in die blutbahn gelangen
gibt es und auch andere kritische
zwischenfälle die zum beispiel ein
herzinfarkt der zu spät entdeckt wird
patienten die aus dem bett fallen also
mehr von uns ist nicht nur für uns gut
sondern vor allem für die patienten es
gibt noch eine weitere frage an sie
nehmen die fälle wahrnehmbar in den
kliniken und altenheimen wieder zu
weiter zu also ich kann ganz klipp und
klar sagen ich kenne keine einzige
station mir fällt zumindest keine ein wo
es nicht eines oder mehrere dieser
isolation zimmer gibt wo diese
multiresistenten keime liegen und vor
zehn jahren bei msa der große renner oh
gott der patient hat mrsa heutzutage ist
man froh wenn es nur der mrsa ist es
gibt wie gesagt immer mehr keime die
gegen immer mehr an die würdiger klassen
resistenz sind und auch keime den man
kaum noch her wird die frage würde ich
gerne an frauen ärgern weitergeben die
whu hat ihre erste strategie zur
eindämmung von
antibiotikaresistenzen im jahr 2001
veröffentlicht ist also tatsächlich
wirklich schon eine weile her aber
gefühlt ist so richtig viel seitdem
nicht passiert wie erklären sie das
ja das ist in der tat nicht so einfach
zu erklären
ich glaube was wir wirklich sehen also
whu wir plädieren auch dafür die die
global leaders group der whu plädiert
auch gerade dafür dass gerade
länder im globalen süden mehr
investieren müssen in die problematik
antibiotikaresistenz warum ist das nicht
passiert ich glaube ein grund dafür ist
dass einfach die datenlage sehr
unvollständig ist also länder wie
deutschland die haben schon seit jahren
ein gut funktionierendes
überwachungssystem der gibt es jedes
jahr gibt es eine berichterstattung die
vom robert koch institut herausgegeben
wird da gibt es eine regionale
berichterstattung
da ist einfach innerhalb der fachgruppen
aber eben auch innerhalb der bevölkerung
eine gewisse
informationslage da wenn es vielleicht
auch nicht auf dem niveau ist wo wir das
gerne sehen wollen
aber es gibt einfach schon relativ gute
zahlen belastbare zahlen
und mit denen kann man eben druck
ausüben auf entscheidungsträger
politiker aber in vielen ländern der
welt ist es nicht der fall da wissen wir
nicht wie viele antibiotika verbraucht
werden da müssen wir noch viel weniger
darüber wie die resistenz lage ist und
wenn man ein problem nicht quantifiziert
dann kann man das ignorieren und das ist
eben was wir sehen und die grundlage zb
für unseren aktionsplan von 2015 ist
eben dass wir informationen von ländern
mit guter datenlage nehmen und sagen wir
wissen dass das problem existiert schaut
danach mesz das problem und guckt was
ihr machen könnte es gibt so viele
maßnahmen die effektiv sind die
kostengünstig sind wir haben über
handhygiene gesprochen wir haben über
infektionen prävention und kontrolle
bisher gesprochen die entsprechende
ausstattung an gesundheitspersonal dass
die genug zeit haben und auch
entsprechend ausgebildet sind es sind
alles maßnahmen die wir kennen die wir
umsetzen können aber die eben auch
vielleicht nicht so sexy sind wie andere
themen die akkus sind und die homann
feuer aus löschen muss und nun wo man
rennen muss und so weiter das ist eine
schleichende pandemie eine massive aber
eine schleichende in gewisser weise die
schwelt im hintergrund und deswegen kann
man sie ignorieren ein freude macht
eigentlich ein feuerlöscher wenn ich
dieses bild jetzt mal verwende wäre ja
die entwicklung von neuen antibiotika
die eben gegen diese multiresistenten
erreger wirksam sind warum passiert da
so wenig in der forschung stichwort
pharmaindustrie
es ist sehr kurz gedacht das ist zwar
ein feuerlöscher aber es ist wirklich
nicht mehr als ein feuerlöscher es ist
ganz wichtig dass man neue antibiotika
entwickelt und investiert aber es ist zu
kurz gedacht und oder wie ein shortcut
fast weil wir wollen ja eben nicht das
neue antibiotika klassen breit verwendet
werden weil die sollen reserve seien die
sollen für patienten eingesetzt werden
die die wirklich brauchen das ist
finanziell für die pharma- und nicht
rentabel weil ja wir wollen ja dann wenn
neue medikamente da sind die nicht an
jeden weitergeben sondern die sollen
wirklich nur sparsam zum einsatz kommt
antibiotika zu entwickeln kostet sehr
viel geld ist sehr langsam und ist eben
auch nur eine lösung auf zeit und die
maßnahmen die ich eben genannt habe sind
auf der wichtigkeit
hierarchie mindestens genauso wichtig
wie neue antibiotika zu entwickeln
aber wäre dann ein denkbarer gang man
braucht ja letztlich neue wirksame
präparate dass die dass die staaten
vielleicht prämien zahlen an die
pharmaindustrie damit sie eben neue
medikamente entwickeln obwohl es für sie
nicht rentabel ist
ja solche ansätze gibt es in der tat
also es gibt diskussionen darüber ist es
vielleicht einfach so wie andere globale
klima sollte man als weltgemeinschaft
mich irgendwie versuchen da tätig zu
werden weil das ist ein problem dass
keine grenzen kennt genauso wie
klimawandel und genauso geht es alle an
und wenn irgendwo in afrika die ganze
sache schiefgeht wird es irgendwann auch
in europa zur problematik werden also
gibt es durchaus diskussionen und auch
mehr als das auch schon eher initiativen
die versuchen gelder von staaten zu
schulen um eben zu sagen hier wir
investieren gemeinsamen einfanden um
eben mit pharmaunternehmen zu arbeiten
um neue antibiotika herzustellen so was
gibt es bereits auch incentives also
anreize werden geschafft aber das ist
noch nicht auf dem niveau dass es
ausreichend werden verlange ich würde
ihn gern noch mal ein statement vorlesen
auf youtube in den niederlanden ist man
sich des problems bewusst und hat im
normalfall kapazitäten für die
quarantäne von neun krankenhäusern
bereits schon seit mehr als zehn jahren
unser system ist krank
hören sie sie von kollegen aus anderen
ländern dass es da einfach besser läuft
dass die das problem besser im griff
haben also ist ja bekannt dass es in den
niederlanden deutlich besser läuft die
haben die keime dort besser im griff es
geht ja schon los wenn bei uns ich meine
wir testen einem patienten jährlich ohne
grund auf multiresistente keime wie kann
es dann sein dass dieser patient der
getestet wurde wo quasi die
wahrscheinlichkeit besteht dass der test
positiv ausfällt ohne vermittlung also
ohne schutzmaßnahmen betreut wird mit
anderen patienten in einem zimmer liegt
und nach vier tagen kommt dann raus oder
hatten multiresistenten keim erst dann
verkehr wird während er vermutlich den
anderen in seinem zimmer schon
angesteckt hat wir als personal
eventuell implizierten aber nicht
getestet werden und da muss ich ganz
klar sagen auch mal meine kritik wird an
der lauterbacher ich bin dreifach
dreimal gegen korona geimpft und muss
mich jeden dienst vor dienstantritt auf
kroner testen mit der begründung man
kann das virus er trotzdem weiter geben
warum ist man nicht so genau auf diese
multiresistente keime warum guckt man
immer nur auf corona corona ist ein
wichtiges thema hat gar keine frage aber
wie gesagt der endgegner der uns
wirklich bevorsteht der uns wirklich den
garaus machen kann sind diese
multiresistenten keime einfach und um
nochmal auf das pharmaindustrie thema
zurückzukommen katrin schreibt es
braucht dringend druck auf die forschung
die antibiotika forschung ist seit
jahrzehnten das stiefkind dass keiner
haben will frau jahrgang ich würde
vielleicht gerne zum schluss noch mal
einen blick in die zukunft werfen gibt
es denn
lösungsansätze zum beispiel habe ich
hier gelesen sekunde auf youtube hat der
der chronik geschrieben sind
bakteriophagen eine ernstzunehmende
alternative zum antibiotikum könnte das
vielleicht einen ausweg sein
also die bakteriophagen die werden schon
seit jahren immer wieder herangezogen
und das hat auch immer wieder mal
untersuchungen gegeben um zu schauen
irgendwie wie sind sind ist das etwas
was uns
wirklich weiterbringen kann
meines wissens nach hat sich das bisher
nicht vollständig nachweisen lassen und
deswegen bleiben wir zunächst einmal
dabei dass es eben nicht eine
wunderwaffe gibt also es ist tatsächlich
ein komplexes thema das auch
umfassende maßnahmenpakete braucht dazu
gehört die entwicklung neuer medikamente
aber eben auch dass
maßnahmen zur optimierung des
antibiotika einsatzes bei mensch und
tier umgesetzt werden dass wir uns an
unsere hygienemaßnahmen halten das sind
sachen von denen wir wirklich wissen
dass sie funktionieren wenn sie richtig
gemacht werden und wenn das jedes land
so machen würde dann hätten wir auch
weniger probleme damit
frau jahrgang verlange ich möchte mich
ganz herzlich bei ihnen bedanken dass
sie heute mit uns auf ein thema geschaut
haben das vielleicht viele einfach so
nicht auf dem schirm haben das aber
durchaus relevant ist ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen abend vielen dank
danke
ja und auch euch herzlichen dank für
eure berichte eures statements eure
fragen und ja wir sehen uns hoffentlich
bald wieder biss dann tschüss
[Musik]